a warning that our first report from our
national correspondent tom parmenter
does start with the sound of the
gunshots that killed her
monday evening
10 pm
the sound of shooting
[Music]
two shots
and then more
[Music]
[Applause]
it's the moment that nine-year-old
olivia pratt corbell was gunned down
in her own home
the fourth and final shot is followed by
this
at the top of the screen two minutes
later the flashes of feet
running away
the police have this footage as they
search for the gunman
the first suspect to be detained was the
one who was already in a hospital bed
the 35 year old man who was being chased
in the shooting that led to olivia's
death he is joseph knee who was out of
prison on license
he was the intended target but only
suffered chest injuries in the shooting
detectives are at aintree hospital and
will question him as to why he was being
shot at here on king's heath avenue
it was a chase that led by chance to
olivia pratt corbell's doorstep
the nine-year-old was behind her mum in
the doorway when she was hit we are
receiving names we are receiving
information people are telling us where
they were and what areas they were in
which is absolutely fantastic i can't
again go into any detail around those
names and clearly we have to do some
work around the names that are being
given to us but people are starting to
come forward with some names
the search here is of course meticulous
everyone wants a breakthrough but these
gangland style shootings are complex
investigations
it all now points to the police knowing
who that gunman is but not yet where he
is he is still on the run and while the
work here at the scene is important
finding him and preventing any further
shootings is their overriding priority
people here are fundraising for olivia's
family who are being supported by the
police
skyler was in the same class
they've all lost a funny mischievous
friend i think i was actually a best
friend to be honest with you we used to
play two four days and stuff and
i gave her a granny wig
did you yeah and um
give her the
top and jacket to put on did you with
the name granny stick i i so she was
always messing around and having fun
yeah yeah she used to love like
love like playtimes and stuff she was
quite funny like she was like
she was quite small and she was funny
yeah
that's how you remember her yeah
that's how i remember
for olivia's sake the prime suspect in
this case has to be found whether he is
in this city still or by now
far away